[موسيقى]
PRX Hunter أجنبي
الليلة ما
هو الآن
[موسيقى]
snail Trail لا يحتاج إلى القابض أو
الكسر ، سيبدأ
رائعًا ولكن من السهل جدًا القيادة بشكل
مثالي
[موسيقى]
واو
رائع ، ونحن على الوراء في القرن
ونحن نصنع شيئًا لطيفًا  والمزيد من الراحة
داخل هذا أمر مهم أيضًا ، فأنت تقوم
ببعض التسهيلات للدخول إلى السيارة والخروج منها
حتى القط لديه بعض وسائل التعليق
التي عند إيقاف السيارة تنخفض
وتنخفض عند إعادة تشغيل هذا يعني أن هذه
المرافق
شيء واحد أنه لطيف أكثر من
سيارتي في سيارة السباق لدينا بعض
القيود ، لذا فيما يتعلق بالقواعد لدينا
400 حصان ومع هذه السيارة تكون
مفتوحة وهذا يعني أن لديها 600 وهذا
شيء جميل
[موسيقى]
هيا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نعم يمكنك الاسترخاء ،
لقد بدأنا في تصميم
سيارتنا في داكار للفوز برالي داكار قبل حوالي أربع أو
خمس سنوات وأثناء هذه العملية
قلنا أنك تعلم أنه يمكننا بالفعل بناء
سيارة على الطريق من نفس الأساس
مثل سيارة داكار  هذا ما تراه
هنا اليوم ، إنه يتمتع بنفس
التصميم الأساسي مثل محرك سيارة داكار نفسه ،
إنه في الواقع أكثر قوة ، إنه يحتوي
على نظام تعليق أفضل ونظام تعليق أطول
وحمل كامل من التحسينات التي
تجعلها جيدة مثل القيادة على
الطريق العام التي قد تقودها  مباشرة
إلى دبي الآن حيث يمكنك القيادة
عبر الصحراء حسنًا
، ثم ذهبنا يسارًا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية